I had that experience I was making a
documentary in Tibet and I was
interviewing a baker in lhasa and he had
been working incredibly hard to use the
barley flour the roasted barley flour
that's traditional there and work out
ways to make it rise with yeast it's
hard to do because you're at high
altitude and he'd done it and he'd put
together this really offbeat Cafe that
sold
a really quirky take on traditional
Tibetan Foods
and I said you must be really proud of
what you've achieved here and he looked
utterly blank just it didn't make any
sense to him that question he was like
no that but we had to cut and like carry
on the interview yeah because it just
didn't make any sense being proud of
what he'd done because he hadn't done it